- Diese Ausbildung ist sehr vielfältig,
[sie] geht natürlich auch in
verschiedenen Abteilungen und Richtungen.
- Wie man mit den Kunden umgehen soll,
umzugehen hat, was man bestellen soll,
also wie bestellt wird.
Wir lernen jede Mengen
Sachen über die Ware,
über den allgemeinen Ladenaufbau,
wie es hier ablaufen soll.
- Er muss sich mit Lebensmitteln
auseinandersetzen.
Er muss Spaß an den Lebensmitteln haben.
- Er muss eigentlich sehr offen sein,
muss blitzschnell umschalten können,
also von der einen Situation in die andere.
- Bei uns ist das so, dass
letztendlich nicht nur gelernte
Mitarbeiter bei uns anfangen können,
sondern die können auch mit einer
Aushilfstätigkeit hier anfangen
und schon mal reinschnuppern oder
eine Art Praktikum machen
und sich dann langsam an
den Beruf gewöhnen.
Und wenn die sagen, Mensch, das ist was
für mich, das passt, da hab ich Lust drauf,
dann sind wir auf jeden Fall zu
einem Gespräch bereit,
wo wir dann über eine Einstellung
sprechen können
beziehungsweise über eine Einstellung
als Auszubildender für Verkäufer,
Verkäuferin oder auch Kauffrau
oder Kaufmann im Einzelhandel.
- Unsere Azubis, die können
wirklich sehr weit kommen.
Also da geben wir denen
wirklich viele Möglichkeiten.
Sie können hier in erster Linie den
Ausbildungsberuf als Verkäufer durchlaufen.
Das wäre eine zweijährige Ausbildung.
Und die zum Einzelhandelskaufmann
wär eine dreijährige.
Und danach kann man noch
seinen Handelsfachwirt machen.
- Bei uns ist es so, dass wir auch
demjenigen die Chance geben,
hier eine Abteilung alleine zu
führen, wo er Möglichkeiten hat,
selbstständig zu bestellen oder auch die
Aufbauten und alles selber machen kann.
Oder wo auch nachher
mehr Sachen sind,
dass er auch in die Marktleitung
mit reinkommen kann,
einen Markt mitführen kann,
erst mal als Substitut,
später eventuell sogar als Marktleiter.
Also da sind letztendlich
Chancen ohne Ende gegeben.
- Ja, einfach der Umgang mit Menschen,
das macht mir besonders viel Spaß.
Dass man sehr viel über die Waren lernt.
Man weiß ja schon nicht viel
über die Ware allgemein,
auch wenn man die selber verzehrt
vielleicht, aber so lernt man auch,
während man damit arbeitet,
wo die Ware herkommt,
wie die hergestellt wird oder
wozu man die auch überhaupt braucht.
Ich finde das Tolle an dem Beruf,
dass man unheimlich viele
Möglichkeiten hat weiterzukommen,
eine selbstständige Arbeit verrichten kann.
Und jemand, der gerne isst
und dazu, sag ich jetzt mal,
ein gutes Glas Wein trinken möchte,
der ist einfach in so einem
Supermarkt richtig aufgehoben.